[موسيقى]
وسط جباله مالايا يتدفق عبر مدينه اليوغا
مدينه ريشيكيش الهنديه نهر الجانجا
بالنسبه للمعتقدات المحليه النهر نابع من
الجنه لتجديد البشر وتطهيرهم من الاثام
والخطايا ويطلقون عليه الام جانجا
احد اكبر الانهار في القاره الهنديه يقدم
ياهه ويغذي اكثر من نصف مليار شخص كام
حقيقيه اكثر من اي نهر في العالم
[موسيقى]
من كل بقاع العالم ياتي المغامرون لتجربه
السباحه في بروده ونقاء نهر الجانجا
وللتجديف رغم كل ما تحمله رحلته من صعوبات
متحمسه جدا ان انا اعمل الرفتينج في الهند
لاول مره في حياتي اعتقد انها تكون اخر
مره لان انا خايفه جدا بصراحه احنا في
الاول هنعدي الناحيه التانيه علشان نقدر
ان احنا نبدا رحله فاحنا لابسين اللايف
جاكيتز دي بس عشان نعدي مش عشان اي حاجه
تانيه ان شاء الله مش هيحصل لنا حاجه يعني
[موسيقى]
احنا دلوقتي رايحين نركب عربيه لحد المكان
اللي هنركب فيه المركب بتاعه الراسنج نلبس
بقى لايف جاكيت تاني وكل حاجه الحمد لله
احنا عدينا بسلام
[موسيقى]
ة لاول مره هنعمل فيها
في الهند
يعني بطولاتي في الالعاب المائيه
ستره الحياه الخوذه والاحبال المحوطه
لزورق التجذيف هي منقذتك خلال هذه
المغامره فالنهروم مليء بالمنحدرات القويه
بما يكفي لقلبي زورق يحمل ثمانيه اشخاص
لذلك تطبيق تحضيرات المدرب ضروره للنجاح
نعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بجانب الادرينالين المتدفق في الجسد طوال
ثلاث ساعات والاربعه والعشرين كيلو مترا
خطف امضاري لون المياه الزمرودي والقمم
الخصبه التي ترتفع بجانب النهر فهذا
المشهد يكفي للنسيان التعب او جزء منه
لاكون صريحه لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي
ريشكش الهند